current drinking age laws they drive
drinking among young people into the
dark and make young people afraid to
call for help if there are health
problems with their friends it's it's
disastrous prohibition didn't work
before and it's not working now hi i'm
michelle fields with reason TV we're
here with Geoffrey Nadal
president of the National Youth Rights
Association thank you for joining us
thank you what is the National Youth
Rights Association so the National Youth
Rights Association is a youth-led civil
rights group and in fact we're really
the only youth led civil rights group in
the United States and what we do is we
were committed to defending the civil
rights of young people educating society
about the value of youth and also this
is a key point empowering young people
to defend their own liberties and that
is really what we do can you talk a
little bit about Kiley's law Android
discriminates against young people and
fails to protect them short now Kylie's
law is a disastrous policy it imposes up
driving curfews on young people it
imposes passenger limits it penalizes
young people for distracted driving
while ignoring the same behavior from
older people and the key point with
Kylie's law is it requires anyone under
21 to place a red decal on their license
plate basically marking them to be
followed by by predators and we've seen
that happen even when parents are
driving driving their children's cars
they people started racing with them
people have come at them aggressively
now the studies actually show that when
young people go through these graduated
driver's license systems that impose
these burdens and restrictions they're
actually less safe because they drive
less and they don't get the real-world
experience they need and they wait
longer to get their license your group
supports lowering the voting age to 16
why good question one of the key points
here is taxation without representation
look our founding fathers fought against
this when when it was imposed on them by
Great Britain and we have the same
problem today 16 and 17 year olds young
people today are paying 10 billion
dollars a year in sales tax a billion
dollars in income tax 80% of young
people work before they graduate high
school and yet they're denied the right
to vote right we have a fourteen point
three trillion
dollar national debt that's causing a
entire crisis as we speak and it's this
generation that is going to have to bear
the burden of that debt yet we have no
voice in our future today what do you
think that the age limit for drinking
should be now this is a very good
question well we're working to do at
this point is to lower the drinking age
to 18 we see it as an absolute travesty
that you know 18 19 20 year-olds are
going overseas fighting our Wars dying
in those wars and you know the the the
soldiers who come back are actually
sometimes being arrested for underage
drinking
current drinking age laws they drive
drinking among young people into the
dark and make young people afraid to
call for help if there are health
problems with their friends it's it's
disastrous prohibition didn't work
before and it's not working now what is
your group's view on age of consent
that's also a very good question our
organization does not take a position on
that it's a very contentious issue and
we certainly hear all sides of it but
that's not something that we address we
have our plateful at this point with a
lot of other stuff what about parents
rights if a guardian or parent is
supporting youth financially should they
have a say over what the kid can do what
we see a lot of times with these
policies that the government's are
implementing is that they don't only
infringe upon fundamental youth rights
but they really infringe upon parents
rights and the rights of families to to
raise their children to decide how how
their children will grow up you know
curfews are our great example of this
because the government steps in and
decides in a heavy-handed manner that
young people can't be outside after a
certain hour can't be outside after
10:00 p.m. and if they are they'll be
arrested and they'll have you know a
misdemeanor on their record instead
let's let's leave this decision to
parents to families where there can be
open dialogue founded upon mutual
respect and where young people and
parents can come to decisions about what
is right for you what is right for us as
a family because these one-size-fits-all
solutions they don't work and they often
have disastrous effects thank you for
joining us Jeffrey it was great talking
with you i'm michelle fields with Reason
TV thank you